[Music]
sometimes it's the simplest of ideas
that can change the world most
profoundly and sometimes it is the most
challenging problems that can have the
simplest solutions access to clean
abundant water supplies is a huge
problem and getting more difficult daily
currently over a billion people don't
have a clean water supply around the
world water related diseases kill an
estimated six thousand people every day
and dirty water is responsible for an
estimated 80% of all infectious diseases
in the world here's part of the problem
in much of the world gathering water is
done the old-fashioned way by walking to
a water source and literally lugging a
day's worth back home but there's no
guarantee this water is clean
[Music]
christena cubic is from plate pumps
international the water is being shared
by cattle goats livestock upstream that
could be contaminating the river people
washing their clothes and possibly doing
other things but in many cases clean
abundant water exists literally right
under people's noses in some cases as
shallow as a hundred twenty feet below
the surface
but for these rural villages that might
as well be Mars even if someone were to
dig them a well they often don't have
the resources to supply the electricity
or diesel fuel needed to run the pumps
that gets the water out of the ground
enter the plate it looks like a merry go
in fact it is a merry-go-round attached
to a pump every spin sends clean water
into a storage tank at the rate of 1400
liters per hour play pump water system
utilizes the power of children playing
so if we can find a community with a
rural school where children are more
inclined to use the pump we've got a
sustainable water supply
[Music]
the pump takes about a day to assemble
to help pay for upkeep the sides of the
storage tank double as billboards
[Music]
that's great
you took about the five minutes of play
and now we got enough water to fill this
bucket the water tastes good
drinkable but that's not the only impact
clean water means less disease available
water means less carrying time
especially for young girls that leaves
more time for school / the girls are now
in a much better position because the
girls are now able to attend class
on time unlike before before they would
go in virtual time and they will have to
join the boys later
so the girls are now able to set the
classes on time that just like everyone
so they now gets equal opportunities
like boys it is a potentially
life-changing technology and the
nonprofit group play pumps international
with the help of groups like the Case
Foundation has set an ambitious goal of
installing 4,000 play pumps all across
sub-saharan Africa by 2010 they estimate
that will bring clean drinking water to
10 million people in 10 different
countries easy to build easy to maintain
the play pub provides a low-cost
solution to a whole host of complicated
expensive problems now that's what I
call a good idea sponsored by National
Geographic mission programs taking
science and exploration into the new
millennium